Australia has become the latest
continent to confirm a case of the
coronavirus which originated in China
three cases have also now been found in
Europe all three appeared in France in
the capital Paris and in the city of
Bordeaux health officials there said a
48 year old patient had been travelling
through China and passed through Wuhan
that's the epicenter of the outbreak
Frances Health Minister said authorities
are not ruling out finding new cases we
are going to do everything possible to
contain this epidemic knowing that it is
possible and even probable that there
will be other cases particularly in
Europe just because there aren't any
other identified cases today doesn't
mean that no other cases are circulating
meanwhile here are the latest numbers in
China the virus has now killed at least
41 people with more than 1300 others
affected authorities are taking
unprecedented measures to try to stop
the spread of the virus travel
restrictions remain in place and over a
dozen cities in China and all of the
countries 70,000 movie theaters have
also been closed the actions are urgent
as millions are on the move over the
Lunar New Year holiday as the scale of
the outbreak grows so too does the
urgency of the response in Wuhan
construction is underway on a new
hospital for coronavirus patients
Chinese authorities say it will be
complete in just over a week the city at
the outbreaks epicenter remains under a
transport lockdown Road checks drivers
with a high temperature are sent to
hospital across China almost 40 million
people face travel restrictions during
the important New Year holiday a lot of
people had no way to get home I really
feel for them because I can understand
what it's like to have been working hard
away from home for a year everyone looks
forward to being with their family but
in this situation there's really nothing
we can do
the outbreak even featured on state
televisions Lunar New Year broadcast
with hosts sending messages of support
to medical staff in airports across the
globe scenes like this are becoming
common officials using thermal monitors
to screen travelers for signs of fever
around the world concern is heating up
well we have team coverage on the spread
of that virus I'm joined now by DW
correspondent Lisa Lewis she is in Paris
and Fabien Kretschmer in Beijing for us
we want to start with Lisa Lisa the
first European cases of the virus have
now been confirmed those are in France
what more can you tell us about the
situation there in those infections well
the authorities have said that all these
three people recently traveled to China
and then came back one person for 48
year old man in Bordeaux in southwestern
France he apparently is from China he's
French he has French nationality he went
to see SOS mid-sized which is an
overnight doctor service over over the
weekend and they very quickly identified
symptoms and also when they learned that
he was actually from Wuhan where the
virus comes from really they put him on
- under quarantine and transferred him
to hospital the authorities here are
saying that two more cases have been
detected in Paris it looks like it was
first one person then someone else who
had been in touch with that person
obviously the authorities are trying to
reassure everybody and saying we've got
everything in place to deal with this
especially as we had to deal with other
diseases that were similar in the past
okay Fabien crutch for now in Beijing
it's the Chinese New Year today but
celebrations not taking place as usual
how is China responding yeah I'm in
Beijing right now and here every I'm the
public gatherings they've been canceled
also the tourist attractions have been
closed - part of also of the Chinese
wall have been closed and there
definitely doesn't feel like the typical
Chinese New Year usually it's also the
season where domestic spending is really
high but now
people prefer to stay at home they don't
go to restaurants they don't spend so
much on gifts for their families so yeah
it definitely feels quite different in
them if you ask the population then
especially among the young there's also
some kind of anger against the local
authorities in Wuhan in in in Hubei
Province because just two days before
they shut down the city you know shut
down all the transportation they were
attending lavish singing song dinners
and they really cannot understand well
the party authorities tell the people to
wear face masks and to avoid all public
gatherings but of course they themselves
are quite differently Lisa what about
there in France what measures are French
authorities taking to stop the spread of
the virus now that we are seeing the
first cases appearing there well the
authorities have said that they are well
prepared there are three specific
hospitals in Paris they are prepared to
deal with such infectious diseases the
Health Minister Anna's Bazar has said
yesterday that people if they had
similar symptoms that they shouldn't go
to see someone at the hospital or
contact their local GP there's a special
helpline they need to call and then
people will come and make some tests at
their home and then maybe bring them to
specialised services obviously the
Health Minister said that she would give
a daily update on the situation she said
they're probably going to be more cases
like this in France and she also said
that probably these cases were first
detected in France because France had
developed as one of the first countries
a method to detect the virus now people
here obviously quite concerned about
this as you look at social media they're
really wondering why there aren't
systematic checks at airports because
there are people who've talked to French
media in the past saying you know I just
got home from kleiner and no one
actually checked me no one controlled me
alright Lisa Lewis with the latest there
in Paris and Fabien Karishma for us in
Beijing thank you to you both